check the sonar do we have a lock on it
50 feet captain I'm reading her to be at
least 28 feet long
28 feet Great Scott legends have told of
the giant sea serpent there
[Music]
the inspiration for legends of sea
serpents and monsters the giant oarfish
is a peculiar animal it's the world's
longest bony fish and has been known to
reach lengths of up to 56 feet of those
we've been able to study they typically
weigh in at around 600 pounds or fish
can be found in every ocean on the
planet except the Arctic they're what's
known as an oceanographic species what
it means the fish's migratory and
travels across the world's oceans
exactly or fish migrate to find their
food mainly plankton and krill while the
fish may be large it has no real teeth
but rather gill rakers that filter out
its food from the ocean water the giant
oarfish is typically a deep ocean fish
its natural habitat is around 3,000 feet
deep but it has often been seen
shallower sometimes as shallow as 60
feet
you know it's strange rather than
swimming schools the giant oarfish
chooses a solitary life circumnavigating
the planet an endless search for food I
like to think it's on a grand adventure
kind of like all of us as we trapped in'
can't you see I'm having a moment
[Music]